we're on problem 65
65 and let's see they wrote 2 4
and 9. and they tell us in the list
above if n is an integer between 1 and
10 inclusive so that means that n could
be 1
and it could be 10 or any number in
between and it's an integer then the
median must be
the median
right not the mean the median so the
median means the middle number right so
let's
so it depends where where let's put all
the other numbers in order right so we
have
eight
eight
nine
and they're essentially saying that n n
could be anywhere in this it could be
one here it could be right here it could
be
it could be well it could be another two
it doesn't tell us it could be any
number it could be two could be another
three it could be a ten we don't know
but before we stick n in here let's
figure out what the middle is
so
if well right here we have eight numbers
so the middle
of the range is actually you know there
is no middle number but when we add n
there will be a middle number so let's
just think about a little bit
if n gets added on if n is 5 or less
right so n goes into this bucket n goes
someplace here
then what happens
then what becomes the middle number
if n is five or less then we'll have n
here
and n might be five n might go right
here but what becomes the middle number
then we have one two three four on this
side of the middle number and we have
one two three four on that side of the
number
so then the median which is just the
middle number becomes five
that's if n is five or less so if n
if n is less than or equal to five
then we know that the median
will be equal to five
now let's do the other opposite thought
experiment what if n
is six or more what if n is greater than
or equal to six
so it goes someplace over here so n will
go someplace here could be 6. i might
have to put it right there but wherever
i put it on this side i'll have 4 to the
right of 6
and i'll have 4 to the left of 6 right n
isn't on this side anymore 4 to the left
of 6. so then the median would be 6.
so then the median would be 6.
and either of these cases have to be
true for n
so the median is either 5 or 6 and that
is choice b
problem 66. i like this brownish color
all right they they're doing this
reminds me of
when i
in middle school math competitions four
6 2 and you add them all together
you add them all together you get 1
1222.
and would they want to know if n and u
represent single digits in the correctly
worked computation above what is the
value of n plus u
so the best thing to do is just try to
work these out and see what happens so 7
plus 3 is 10 plus 2
is 12.
so you would write a 2 here which they
already wrote and carry a 1.
and now we have 1 plus u let me write
this down 1
plus u
plus
two
plus six
is equal to
well it's either going to be equal to
two or
or some digit and a two so let's just
think about it a little bit
one plus u plus 2 plus 6 that's equal to
u
plus 9
u plus 9 is going to have to equal
something
right
so if u is 9
so and it has to be something that ends
with a two and remember u has to can
only be between
you can only be between zero and nine
right it's a digit it has to be an
integer it has to be a digit
so let's think about let's think about a
little bit it has to be something that
ends in a two so the only way the only
next thing above 9 that ends as a 2 is
12
right
because because you can't get to 22 to
get to 22 you would have to add 13 and
you can't be 13. so
this has to be a 12 so u has to be equal
to 3 right that's the only possibility
that will give you something that ends
in a 2.
so if we assume that u is 3 then we have
1 plus 3 plus 2 plus 6
which is 12 carry the 1
you get 1 plus 4
1 plus 4 plus n
plus
1
is equal to 12.
so you get
1 plus 4 plus 1 that's 6 plus n is equal
to 12
and n would be equal to 6.
and they want to know what n plus u is
so n plus u 6 plus 3 that's equal to 9
and that is choice b
b
9.
67
67.
look at that this is a dense looking one
but let me write down the little
equation they wrote on top r is equal to
400
times
d
plus s
minus p
all of that
over p
if stock is sold three months after it
is purchased the formula above relates p
d s and r where p is the purchase price
of the stock that's the purchase price
d is the amount of any dividend received
fair enough
s is the selling price of the stock
and r is the yield of the investment as
a percent
fair enough
if rose purchased 400 worth of stock so
p
is equal to four hundred dollars
received a five dollar dividend so d is
equal to five dollars and sold the stock
for 420
so sold the price for 420
for three months after purchasing it so
this formula applies because there's a
formula for selling after three months
what was the yield of her investment
according to the formula assuming she
paid no commissions well this is we just
substitute in so let's see
the yield would be equal to 400
times
5
plus 420
minus 400 right p is 400
all of that over 420
that is equal to let's see 420 minus 400
is 20 plus 5 that's 25.
25.
so it's 400
times 25 over
this shouldn't be 420 right this is p
the price you paid is 400
25 over 400
right
i just substituted these values into
this equation
this cancels out and i'm just left with
a yield of 25 and it's probably in terms
of percent yep 25
e
all right problem 68
let's switch colors
68 the temperatures in degrees celsius
recorded at six in the morning in
various parts of a certain country
in a certain country were
10
degrees i'm not gonna write all that
five
minus two
minus 1
minus 5
and 15
and 15. what is the median of these
temperatures the median just means the
middle don't confuse that with the
average which is the mean
or the mean which is the average median
means middle so let's put them in order
and figure out the middle so the
smallest of these numbers is minus five
cross it out then we have minus two
cross it out then we have minus one
cross it out
then we have 5
cross it out then we have 10
cross it out then we have
15.
so the median so this this is
interesting about median if there is no
true middle number right you have 3 on
this side of negative 1 and you are
negative 1 and less and you have 3 on
that side so there's no middle number
because we have an even number of
numbers so what you want to do is you
take the two middle numbers
which are negative 1 and 5 and you
average them
so negative 1 plus so it's negative 1
plus 5
over 2 is equals 4 over 2 which is equal
to
2
2 degrees celsius which is choice c
problem 69.
69
if y
times 3x
minus 5
over 2
is equal to y
and y does not equal 0
then x is equal to what well the
simplest thing since y isn't equal to 0
we can divide both sides of this
equation by y you divide both sides by y
divided by y is 1 y divided by y is 1.
so then we're left with
three x minus five over two
is equal to one
multiply both sides by two you get three
x minus five is equal to two
add five to both sides three x is equal
to 7
and you get x is equal to 7 over 3 which
is choice c
c
and i'm out of time so i'll see you in
the next video